[Applause]
happy Thursday everybody you look
fantastic I'm lying but I'm so excited
because it's time for
if you look into the mirror
and you don't like what you see
Brian Merlin next morning you can change
you know it's time to
[Applause]
Oh's new name
a return
I'll never be the same
if you've got a feeling oh there's
something you would like
to just switch your pronouns and refuse
to switch them back yeah
all right all right all right
president zielinski was just in New York
for the U.N General Assembly to plead
for more help for Ukraine meaning more
money more weapons and fewer visits from
Sean Penn
unfortunately he didn't get to meet with
President Biden too bad he was looking
forward to almost shaking his hand
but zielinski missed a lot more than
high-fiving the zombie in Chief he also
didn't know that the spokesperson for
his own military was this American
person
yeah just an All-American Girl one who
makes Leah Thomas look like Reese
Witherspoon
next week the teeth of the Russian
Devils will gnash ever harder and the
Rabid Mouse will foam in uncontrollable
frenzy as the world will see a favorite
Kremlin propagandist pay for their
crimes and this puppet of Putin is only
the first Russia's war criminal
propagandist will all be hunted down and
Justice will be served sorry Lady
Justice would be served if someone
bought you a better wig I also apologize
to everyone on the west coast watching
this at dinner time especially if you're
having sausage
so zelinski didn't know who Sarah Ashton
cirilla was a deeply strange transgender
spokesperson good for him I usually
don't find out that damsel is a dude
until we're back at the hotel
but now the Ukrainian military has
suspended Sarah for being a massive
psycho on social media viewers might
also remember this one if you look at
Putin's mouth you'll notice that blood
drips from it he's a vampire carrying
out genocide against both ukrainians and
Russians alike
Vlad Putin bathes in the blood of
innocent children and enjoys it
and this is why the dictator of the
Russian Federation must be deposed
doesn't it seem hypocritical for a trans
person to be insulting vampires
after all they come from Transylvania
it seems nice if by nice you mean bad
crazy
so this isn't really about Sarah being
trans at all it's that she's insane and
an American spokesperson for a foreign
war
I don't get it and yeah Putin is a bad
guy true he makes Ivan the Terrible seem
like Ivan the not so bad once you get to
know him
and if you ever meet Putin my advice is
don't stand near any open windows that
breeze you feel is an oligarch flying by
from the floor above you Vlad has had
more enemies whack than anyone although
there is a close second
who this was and claims he never
approved Ashton Cirillo's hiring but
then there are a lot of things zelenski
doesn't know like how to find green
shirts at Old Navy that fit
but it's as if that gets him off the
hook and by hook I mean Sarah's penis
I know but zielinski not knowing about
this person who could have predicted
that
it doesn't make any sense I don't know
who who they are but does what has
anyone asked zielinski about you know
he's comfortable with this person oh no
they should yeah they should put that to
him Tom shallou his slogan should be
he's as smart as he is white
so why is the Kev HR department finally
involved it's not because poor Sarah
requested time off for a prostate exam
and a pap smear it's because this nut
job with a nut sack is going after U.S
citizens last week Senator JD Vance sent
a letter to Secretary of State Anthony
blinken asking who the hell this person
is and why a U.S citizen is acting as a
spokesperson for a foreign government
and why he she and or it keeps going
online and saying crazy things
I mean who does Sarah think she is Joy
Behar
so Vance wants to know what we want to
know who is this clown why isn't
American acting as a spokesperson for
the Ukrainian military and who's paying
for all this and why does he keep giving
me flashbacks of my eighth grade lunch
lady
now I clutch my privates when I hear the
words tater tots
this cuckoo clock responded to the
Senator's inquiry with yet another
deeply odd video
while in Ukraine we are fighting for
Global Liberty and the ideology of
Victory too many in Moscow and across
the world are still caught up in
focusing on the tire Trope of gender
chaos
sorry champ this statement about gender
chaos might carry more weight if it
wasn't coming from a guy named Sarah
I mean how can Ukraine not win with this
person involved
look it's just that after 250 years of
the U.S military you're the first
spokesperson to tuck in their balls
before getting dressed
healing gen sacky's hair
so how did Sarah get this far in the
military our military the Oddball holds
the rank of Junior Sergeant which means
someone promoted this I guess being a
protected class opens every door and not
just the ones to the girls locker room
but does Sarah want to finish by stating
anything unequivocally
I'll finish by stating unequivocally
that I only answer to three groups of
people my Ukrainian commanders the
Ukrainian people and the American
taxpayer
well he left out the girls at the Macy's
makeup counter who helped him hide his
five o'clock shadow
but he says he answers to American
taxpayers well okay as an American
taxpayer I demand an answer do you get
yeast infections or jock itch
but also what the hell is going on over
there yes they're fighting a war I
should know I'm paying for it
but they had no idea this charmer was
going online and saying all this bizarre
on their behalf it's like the equivalent
of the head of Fox News Fox News not
knowing that kill Mead still works here
but it's like everything else in this
Administration no one knows what the
hell comes out of Joe's mouth either
and between Sam Brinton and Rachel
Levine we don't have an Administration
we have a live theatrical rendition of
Tootsie
maybe Sarah's the perfect metaphor for
this war soaking up a lot of money
relying on rhetoric instead of reality
all while making Grand speeches about
freedom but if you look closer you won't
like what slaps you in the face
[Applause]
he grew up in New York and he has a
criminal record to prove it comedian
Christa Salvador
only the Tasmanian devil can outspin her
communications director had never back
down back Aaron perini
she's precocious ferocious and in the
early stages of osteoporosis New York
Times best-selling author and his
contributor Kat Tim
and finally he never wrestles with the
truth New York Times best-selling author
comedian and former NWA world champion
Tyrus
Chris good to see you here thank you you
look great you look great I thought that
honestly that whole time when I was
seeing those videos of the Ukrainian
trans spokesperson I thought it was you
I was like what is Gutfeld doing
it is kind of impressive I was like
literally I was like that's wild but I
was like okay well but doesn't it appear
to be like a skit it does it's one of
those things where you know whatever you
want to do be trans don't be trans cut
whatever you want off I don't care I'm
all supportive but this seems like a
little uh it seems a little nuts but you
know it's I mean she has big nuts but it
it's yeah I don't I don't know to me
there feels like it's one of those
things again where it's like a
distraction I don't buy it yeah the
thing is I think your point is well
taken that being trans is the least
problematic thing about this right yeah
I mean it's she's crazy and she's a
spokesperson for a foreign government
Aaron do you buy silency's excuse that
he had no idea I guess I could what do
you think absolutely I think that that's
completely legitimate I don't think that
this is the best way to get a message
across and it doesn't have anything to
do with her being trans it has to with
the incredibly odd rhetoric she
continues to use and there's already a
lot of issues going on with the Ukraine
war that's why you're seeing in the
capital right now funding fights about
whether or not we're going to continue
to help support the war between the
house that's run by Republicans and the
Senate that's run by democrats and this
is all perpetrated by Joe Biden we got
to remember where this started if Joe
Biden hadn't capitulated to Vladimir
Putin on the Nordstrom 2 pipeline we
wouldn't be looking at any of this today
because he wouldn't have ceded power for
the Russians to go in against Ukraine
that was about the pipeline yes this is
where this nordstream 2 pipeline the
fact that he allowed that to move
forward was what allowed Russia to
circumvent Ukraine when it came to oil
and that is why they didn't need to that
they felt that they could move in I told
you that I know I thought you were full
of crap dude I told you that at the gym
you don't listen he had an amazing
three-point presentation Charles Payne
was there to do the numbers unbelievable
he only listens to women you were
telling me that during my leg day yes no
I don't during my life all right Kat is
this a microcosm of the war no one knows
what the hell is going on and all we get
is rhetoric uh what do you think yes yes
I think it's also I think it's so it is
entirely possible that zielinski had no
idea this was happening but I had no
idea that was happening is also what I
say I say when I'm called on not talking
about something that I didn't want to
talk about I think a lot of us do that I
also think that it looks very much like
not just a sketch but a sketch that we
would do for this show right and by that
I mean takes five minutes yes shot on an
iPhone and the wig is ten dollars you
he's really in Ukraine I don't know
I'm like why don't I do this why didn't
I decide to say I'm the spokesperson for
whatever all the time and you just you
just get the little green screen and you
just like talk like this and all of a
sudden you're a spokesperson yeah no I
don't get it I don't get it what do you
think time to get well okay first of all
first of all a cat thousand percent
correct let's just go back to the
backdrop okay okay all right have you
ever seen a military
press conference without other people in
uniforms there no yeah that's a good
point yeah
have you ever seen one especially that
represents America without American flag
next to the country that we're we're
speaking of and there's usually two
marines guarding make sure everything's
right
was that there no no it was not okay
this and the opening line was
I was on the front line as a medic yeah
during a war
where people getting killed and maimed
and they pulled you off from saving
people
to do that
right there I don't need cows but I
smell yeah okay when the front when
you're thank you thank you to my
Wisconsin people
if the if you're opening segment as you
were doing something so important and so
amazing and brave but you decide to pull
yourself out yeah so you could talk
about vampires this and here's the thing
we know one thousand percent who's
paying this person it's zielinski had no
idea yeah look open up a a photo album
of the people working for lozinski right
now and open up a photo album of the
people working for our white house right
now where does he fit in yeah that makes
sense and no one says anything and the
reason why cat can't do it is because
they would still attack cat for being a
woman she's a fraud and she's a liar you
can't attack him for what he's doing
because if you attack him you put other
trans people in general marginalized
classes that's what's that's what does
not represent anyone myself this is a
sick individual who's doing this
themselves and no one will say hey this
is wrong yeah you know I'd like to point
out that much like the Canadian teacher
with giant boobs we were on to this
story for first and we always get
results and yet where are our Emmys or
pull its pulitzers or even Nobel Peace
prizes I don't know I'm not trans
although some people what I think I am
believe it or not yeah good for you wow
there's still time you know you
literally bragged about having the
biggest one it like broke the internet
and then it's all a lie all right I know
I love the comment on that video
someone's like I didn't realize cat was
trans
oh yeah you go girl hey Sean Hannity
here hey click here to subscribe to Fox
News YouTube page and catch our hottest
interviews and most compelling analysis
you will not get it anywhere else